if you think about Jay-Z in the
beginning of his career the first thing
he did was he learned how to rap all
right that was you know maybe he had
Rhythm that was a skill and then he
turned he figured out how to do the
lyrics okay and then he figured out how
to put those together started to make a
little bit more and then he started
learning how to promote so he started
promoting himself another skill
significantly more money and then after
that figured out how to do a record
label and distribute even more money and
then after that he figured out how to
recruit other artists and get them sound
on his label even more money and so what
happens is that he still needs these
early skill sets even though he didn't
monetize them hard there he monetized
them big later and so skills will
compound